clément gignac économiste en chef à
l'industrielle alliance était avec nous
encore ce soir monsieur gignac bonsoir
commencions par les individus à ce qui
est annoncé le 27 milliards des directs
pour les gens qui en ont besoin qu'ils
sont forcés de rester à la maison et c
est ce que vous est-ce que c'est comment
vous jugez l'ampleur de l'aide là c'est
suffisant c'est bien ton meilleur en dix
ans sans que je faisais que sortirait de
base ou gobain c'est une première étape
je pense que puits d'eau munitions je
pense qu'ils ont gardé leur manche le
compresseur ces deux sentiments mais ce
que j'aime mais sur wiiware c'est que
c'est sûr je sais que vous et moi on a
plusieurs personnes vous écoute on a
besoin de chai mais ce qui
malheureusement sont en congé sans solde
et ont besoin de fario d'épicerie sûr
c'est important deuxièmement on cite les
actions financières le faisait déjà ce
n'était pas très connu mais le
maintenant à lever ses finances lequel
on nous dit si j'avais des difficultés
parce que vous perdez votre emploi
on sait pas combien de temps sauf entre
deux vaccins leur rencontre au haut puis
des gens l'économie repart mais vous
allez voir paraître peu mais j'aurai
besoin de faire vous même
de sorte que ce ça va enlever un stress
on est déjà assez de stress s'occuper là
à écouter d une nouvelle santé publique
renault vers ce que l'on peut tuer
enlever ce stress le financier est ce
que ça fait excusez vous a marché et en
plus on soulève temporairement des
engagements financiers
le soulagement des engagements
financiers des hypothèques des prêts etc
est ce que c'est une proposition que la
mine et des finances fait aux
institutions ou site une forme
d'obligation à direct là autrement dit
elles seront sur les institutions nous
avons travaillé pendant dans une banque
japonaise
mais sanchez d'avoir travaillé
l'audacieux comme du côté de troyes et
comme des finances pendant le g20 c'est
vous quoi ce sera quand même très
mauvaise et b pour une crèche ou une
banque de refuser un accommodement
quelqu'un qui viendrait à personne
je pense que
le téléphone sonnerait site et/ou
président de cette caisse sur cette
banque l'a donc clairement qu'elle
menait ses finances les îles tout vent
clairement c'est été négocié en
coulisses
vous savez on est critiqués bull cour
fédérale ont trouvé que ça prenait un
peu de terre premièrement santé publique
ces premières mais leur tâche est
difficile
et c'est un peu un scénario qu'on a
envisagé vendredi dernier donc on était
attaché c'est en fin de semaine puis
même le 10 juillet en plus de caisses
desjardins se relève de québec est alors
que vous la tâche et celle et l'offre
assez impressionné on a vu cette tâche
et tout se lit chez 27 milliards on a
créé des tps plus des banques
je suis très impressionné petit annoncé
aujourd'hui que gignac ça c'est pour les
individus réplique qui est attendu qu'il
souhaitait puis qui sera là pour
l'économie essayer de ralentir la chute
libre
s'il met un parachute sur l'économie
mondiale qui tombe qui tombe qui tangue
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire et qu'est ce
qui est fait puisque ça sera efficace ou
pas ok il manque encore un morceau ce
pas eux ayant tout ça dans l'utah va
dessiner le futur mais ils vont dévoiler
paraîtra vendredi dernier voulait
s'assurer qu'on donne les liquidités
pour que les banques et les liquidités
pour toutes ces entreprises là qu'ils
ont besoin tapis le lignes de crédit
donc là on a fait ce vendredi l'or vient
d'annoncer pour les travailleurs ceux
qui sont affectés s'élèvera déchets
d'après faut pas qu'on vire en
dépression faut s'assurer que la plupart
des gens qui te regardent qui auront
perdu leur emploi
ben là il faudrait commencer magazine
hello et leur faut qu'on se mette en
récession donc si je vous disais être
passé mes recommandations verrons bien
ce qu'ils vont faire
on élimine la tps pour soit 30 jours
moi j'ai l'impression que vous avez
pensé des gens qui ne regardent que je
devrais commencer mais mois négocié mon
contracteur mes travaux une rénovation
acheter mes potes et n'a pas fait
changer mon auto peut priver de toute
façon j'avais prévu de changer puis mon
voyage là que j'avais peut-être
planifier ma croisière pendant un an
mais on pourrait peut-être le fixie de
suite on perd pas la dps ça c'est ce qui
s'en vient c'est l'étape d'après faut
encourager des gens de penser sinon ces
secteurs manufacturiers
retomber en récession oui mais clément
gignac si les magasins pour l'essentiel
ferme on voit plein d'exemples un peu
partout au pays
cl il ya des concessionnaires qui
ferment fort il a annoncé l'arrêt de la
production en ontario est-ce que c'est
suffisant est-ce qu'on n'est pas prêt
devant une récession qui va durer un
certain temps mais c'est pour ça que ça
prendra pas des semaines avec élimina
tps ils confondent la même chose en
europe vont rythmer la tp la tva ils
vont faire la même chose aux états unis
parce que le c'est sûr qu'on se côtoie
depuis tout aux jo y'a plus personne
dans ce mail petit mais resterait il ya
personnel conception d'un retour aux
yeux moins que 50 personnes dont au
moins dix fois moins que dix personnes
concessionnaires donc vous éviter que
90% des gens qui pour l'instant ont
encore leur emploi déclenché une
dépression en changer leurs
comportements
donc c'est pour ça qu'on doit y aller
avec une grosse dose d'injection
tendance en europe où des semaines avec
une concertation des pays du g7 pour la
prochaine et à stimuler la demande pour
éviter que le consommateur se met lui
même en récession en contraction
laurent leroy dépôt là on verra s'ils
vont adopter votre conseil clément
gignac on va se reparler toute façon
plusieurs fois difficile de faire des
prévisions à moyen terme instruit aline
semaine à la fois qu'imaginer et que la
maison chez faire de l'industrielle
alliance merci désir